[Music]
my name's Andrew machete Solutions
Architect with Google clouds healthcare
and life sciences team and one review
for you today some of the tools that we
have for doing different types of
genomic analyses on Google cloud so
first a brief introduction to our team
the healthcare and life sciences team is
a multifunctional team investing in
building products that are specific to
these industries we also work to help
deploy these solutions with customers
and then scale through partners to help
expand and expedite that development
today we're going to focus on a number
of tools for biomedical research ranging
from public data set hosting to our
pipelines api product some workflow
orchestration tools for doing both
genomics and other research workloads
we'll cover a few open source tools that
we have and some integrations in the
space as well and finally we'll get into
some large-scale analytics at the end so
on the topic of public datasets GCP
hosts a number of public datasets from a
variety of industries some of those from
genomics these public datasets are
available for you to query up to a
terabyte a month for free and then as a
data host you also have the ability to
bring your own datasets and we have a
public hosting program that you can get
in touch with if there's something that
you think is beneficial or you can also
just host your own make it public if
you'd like or access control that
however you'd like to control who you
want to give that to and when you're
hosting these public datasets whoever is
doing the actual usage so the analytics
is going to be responsible for any of
the costs of the querying or the egress
costs if they're in buckets so as a data
host you know that you only pay for the
storage and you're not responsible for
any of the computation that someone
might do so in genomics we host a number
of datasets including thousand genomes
the Illumina Platinum genomes TCGA the
missing database for autism
simon's genome diversity project as well
as some others and we provide these in
both the raw files that are available in
Google Cloud storage buckets and then we
provide them in bigquery as well where
those datasets are available for you to
do analysis or to actually compare those
with some of your own data sets that you
could bring in the similar space we also
host a number of annotation sources
including clinvar and cosmic and these
can be used for sample annotation
pipelines and there's a number of sample
queries available online as well
showing how to join these with other
datasets such as those that you might
bring on your own so this is our page
for the genomics public datasets page
and we'll take a look at it here in a
second but at the top you can see we've
got links to both the bigquery and the
storage buckets or we can actually
browse it by specific datasets to see a
little more detail so if we look at this
here and we go to that dataset page
again the top has both the storage and
the bigquery and in the bottom we can go
to one of the individual data sets so if
we go to thousand genomes for example
you'll be able to see all the
specifications of of which tables we
have in there broken down by where they
are what versions and then what's in a
storage bucket versus what's available
in bigquery if we go into that here you
can see for example the phase 3 of
thousand genomes we can go to the VCF
s-- and go ahead and browse through that
full sample size the full sample set and
these are available for you to test your
own workflows or to use as well in
bigquery we can go here to see the
variant annotation datasets and this
actually includes both the annotations
as well as the other datasets so on the
left here you can see one is the
annotations the other one being the
variants and the various tables that are
a part of each of those so next I'd like
to cover one of our main products in
this space and that's pipeline's API
it's also referred to as genomics API
which was an earlier name of the product
the usage being almost exclusively for
genomics to start the product now is
available for any sort of research
workload and it works well for genomic
pipelines but also can handle other
things as well
so even though we can do other things
one of the more common uses of it is to
do secondary analysis and in this case
we can use it to run standard tools such
as gatk or other optimized machine
learning tools such as deep variant by
using pipeline's API we can optimize for
time and cost through a number of
different ways these include things like
parallel execution being able to use
GPUs or TP use our tensor processing
units persistent disk and different disk
types as well as different instances
such as preemptable instances which are
instances that are much cheaper but may
get shut down if there's a spike in
demand we also work with a number of
workflow engines to incorporate directly
with pipeline's API and you can see some
of those partners here and then also
some partners who provide their own
solutions in this space such as fire
cloud and Terra DNA stack seven bridges
BC platforms and a number of others the
work that we're doing in this space is
informed by the interest that we see in
the industry so if there are things that
you're using or partners you're working
with that aren't available reach out
we'd love to hear some feedback on that
so we know what we can do to help drive
the industry forward so some of the
workflow engines that we integrate with
include Cromwell D sub next flow is a
newer one that we now incorporate with
and then we're working with a number of
others as well to bring that support to
the other workflow engines now the
advantage of working with a workflow
engine is it abstracts away the process
of you having to start the VMs manage
the whole process of that and what you
provide is the container that has the
task you want to run
you include the VM and so any of the
specifications you have for that VM
ranging from a very high-level
definition where you might just say you
want a standard one instance all the way
down to the point where you can
configure the number of CPUs which CPU
architecture you need if you're taking
advantage of some of the newer Intel
chips the ability to attach GPUs and TP
use and specify which ones you want and
different disk types as well which can
include SSDs even locally attached SSDs
if you really need that throughput so
when you're using the workflow engine
now it's easier for you to run these in
various environments and not have to
change everything just to move to Google
Cloud you don't have to learn the
intricacies of the API because we've
done that work with the workflow engines
themselves so you just define the tasks
you have and the workflow engine will
make those calls for you another benefit
of this is that you don't have to
monitor the status of all of the tasks
as they go through and the workflow
engine will track when an operation
starts what needs to come next when it
should start one and if it needs to
retry a certain task due to failure or
preemption so when we use pipeline's API
it starts these operations using a
container for each task again you define
the resources that you need for each
task and this is something that you can
specify at an individual task level
instead of just the entire pipeline so
you can really start to optimize for
each task and you can realize which
parts need high throughput which parts
need memory and maybe only a certain
part that needs an attached accelerator
like a GPU or certain parts of it that
may be more suitable to being preempted
if you can restart them so we'll take a
look here at a demo of using Cromwell to
run the germline snips and in Dells from
gatk best practices and the demo we're
going to look at is actually two
separate pipelines and so what we have
here is Cromwell in a container and the
first pipeline we send the container
that includes Cromwell and the inputs
that we provide
to that or the Whittle the workflow
definition and then a list of the inputs
and options we want for the run
so that first VM we start is actually a
VM with Cromwell once that's up and
running it then will start the full
pipeline here of gatk and then it'll run
through all of those again the one with
Cromwell when it's finished it knows
that then it'll shut down as well
through pipelines so it allows you to
manage all of that without having to
install something specifically now if
you have a working instance of Cromwell
installed somewhere else you can
definitely use that but this is an
opportunity we provide to show how you
can do it without needing to install
anything on your own so to start this
here we're gonna clone a couple of
repositories with the code we're using
here and set some environment variables
about where we want our input and
outputs to go and then the command that
we start here there's a few options if I
know it's a little small here but we
include things like the region in the
zone where we want the job to run the
input files the output locations where
we want to save our logging as well and
once we run it at the bottom we get an
operation ID so that number there this
allows us to follow up and track that
operation if we need to troubleshoot or
maybe come back later and in the UI here
if we go to the genomics part of the of
the cloud console you see a list of
operations here and we can track when
they've been completed we can look at
the tags to see what part of the tasks
they were so once that's all completed
we can now see the output of these in a
Google cloud storage bucket and this
includes you know our final output that
we were looking for it includes any of
the logs from different tasks throughout
as well as standard out and standard
error so if we need to go back and
troubleshoot a particular task
we have the ability to go back and see
that and then any of the work
intermediates as well that we may have
saved either for checking or doing QC
and QA
so here we'll go to the storage bucket
and as we go in here you'll see that in
the work we've got this job ID and this
is what correlates to the job we just
ran you can see here a different folder
for each one of those calls so each of
the tasks we used and coming in here
again we can see the output from those
and the errors and logging so if we need
to come back and check that going to the
output folder we have all of the
different outputs from the various tasks
that were part of this this includes
some metrics and reports that were
generated as a part of that process and
then also we can go through here to see
the index and our VCF as well which is
kind of our end goal the next example is
using d-sub and so when we use d-sub
here we're actually going to install
d-sub in the cloud shell so again you
don't have to install anything on your
own machine and you can run the entire
thing just from the cloud so the example
we're going to use here is using data
from thousand genomes to do indexing and
we're going to use Sam tools in a docker
container to do that so we're going to
start again by cloning the repository
with what we need and I'm going to
install d-sub in a virtual environment
again this is running in that cloud
console so I don't have to worry about
installing or maintaining that the
command to run it here is very similar
to the last one if you see some of the
options here we provide a zone we
provide an input and output the
container that we want to use and then
once that's running we can actually go
and track the resources that it's
generating as well so if we come to the
compute engine page you can see this is
the instance as well that's been started
that's actually running that job and
then going to storage we can go ahead
and see the output from that as well as
some of the logs such as standard out
and error if we need to troubleshoot
some of that
next up is deep variant so deep variant
is a snips and in Dell variant collar
and that uses deep neural networks
excuse me and this is developed as a
collaboration between Google research
and verily life sciences and the cloud
healthcare and life sciences team
partnered with them to optimize this for
cost and speed running on GCP and if you
look at the documentation pages for deep
variant in our cloud documentation
there's a couple different settings we
provide there of a version that's
optimized for time and a version that's
optimized for cost and we can do this by
using different resources attaching GPUs
for example and by changing that we can
find the right trade-off between cost
and time that works for your business or
your research so in this case we're
going to run deep variant from a docker
container very similar to the last ones
so we'll take a look at the script here
that's going to start deep variant again
we set a number of variables at the
beginning such as our project the input
the reference genome that we want to use
the zone where we're going to have this
run and then at the bottom is the
command that's making the call to
pipeline's API and that will look very
similar to the last ones as well so once
we start it we get that operation ID
and this one will jump ahead here and we
can go ahead and look at the output in
our storage bucket and get to that VCF
file as well one of the newest additions
we have here is next flow who recently
added this a couple of months ago if
you're not familiar next flow is a
multi-platform workflow engine that
supports a variety of backends ranging
from various cloud providers to on-prem
to HPC clusters to even running locally
and what we built in here in working
with the community to develop this is
the ability for you to choose Google
pipelines and Google cloud platform as
the backend that you want to where you
want to run those tasks so this allows
you to take an existing workflow that
you have that may be running somewhere
else
and you can now move that to run with
pipeline's API by changing the executor
and then a couple of the settings in
there as well again the things like
project machine types and then in this
case it'll use pipeline's API as the
backend for that and so all of your
computation then we'll run through
pipelines on Google compute engine
there's also an option with next flow
where next flow can set up a cluster
directly on GCE
with configurable master and worker
nodes so that's an option you can use as
well the example we're going to look at
here is with running an RNA seek
proof-of-concept that's using pipeline's
API as the backend again we're going to
do this whole thing in the cloud shell
so we don't actually have to install the
next full application on our local
machine although you can if you'd like
but we'll show a demo here of doing it
all in the cloud and then we're gonna
use that installed version of next flow
that's in cloud shell to go ahead and
run our pipeline so let's take a look at
the config here our next flow config and
you'll see at the top there where we set
Google pipelines and this is where you
would change that depending where you
want it to run we then set a couple of
specific options such as the instance
types we want to use in the project and
then we'll go ahead and start that
version of next flow right now running
in the cloud as the tasks go through
you'll see an ID on the left there and
we can use those to track the resources
like we saw before going in to the
operations and compute engine to
actually see which instances are doing
which which tasks and follow up on those
next up we'll get into variant
transforms so variant transforms is a
tool that we open sourced for
transforming and processing VCF files to
bring them into bigquery to do analytics
now variant transforms runs using
dataflow which if you're not familiar
supports the Apache beam SDK in both
batch and streaming mode although in
this case we're going to use it in batch
and then variant transforms also
supports both direct runner and dataflow
runner and you can pick which one of
those is ideal for your
for the operation you're running so some
of the challenges that we face in
tertiary analysis include trying to
analyze large amounts of data and join
that with public datasets or perhaps
with data sets that we're receiving from
a collaborator or at a different
facility the ability to join those
variants with different annotation
sources where we're trying to understand
an annotation specific to that organism
we have tasks like QA and QC that we're
doing we may have multi sample
processing as well and then doing things
like Association analysis population
analysis G wasps so for all of those
things bigquery is a great tool for that
we'll get into that in a second here but
to be able to support that we really
need a way to import this data into
bigquery in a reliable reproducible way
with a standard format and variant
transforms is what does that for us
so variant transforms uses parallel
batch processing and data flow to do
this
reading in VCF files either single files
multiple files and then we'll end up
dumping those into a bigquery table now
in addition to importing we realize that
sometimes you may have a tool that still
needs VCF files the reality is a lot of
things have already been written
and they may not have an integration
with bigquery and so you may need the
VCF files back variant transforms also
supports pulling things back out of
bigquery to give you a VCF file so you
can maybe identify a subgroup from your
data that's in bigquery export that to a
VCF that you can then put into your
other tools and really use bigquery as
that storage as well another recent
addition to variant transforms is
support for doing annotations and right
now we have support for doing vet
annotation either importing something
that's been annotated or performing
annotation on a data set that you
already have as we continue this
development we're looking at other
annotation sources as well so if there
are others that you're interested in or
something that would be useful
again we'd love to hear the feedback
there and see what would be useful for
you at the end of the talk we've got a
mailing list and I'll point that out but
if you've got feedback or questions feel
free to send it to that group and we'd
love to hear from you so this example
here looking at this screenshot is
running variant transforms on the 2500
samples of thousand genomes and this
particular set is about 81 million
variants so it ends up being an 81
million row table and the screenshot
we're looking at is the data flow
console in Google Cloud console and you
can see here this this task is about a
hundred days of compute time and we've
completed it here in just under two
hours
but you'll notice we could go faster if
we look at the right that blue line on
the chart where that kind of plateaus so
that line is the number of workers that
we had working on the task and you can
see it hit a limit there which was the
quota that I have assigned and in this
case I have had a quota set for four
disk space for how much SSD I was
willing to use at the same time so you
can use things like these quotas to help
control costs or figure out how much
you're willing to do at a single time in
this particular case it scaled up to
about 400 workers and then that's where
it stopped if you wanted to increase
that we can increase the time it'll be
done faster and again that's where you
get into the balance of cost versus time
now in running it with more disk space
you're obviously going to pay for more
disk space but you'll have much less
compute time and so that's where you
start to balance the differences in cost
of compute purses cost of storage so the
next sample we'll take a look at is
basically running this on a smaller
subset of data that's about a hundred
variants we use that just for scale so
when we take a look at the script we're
going to use to run variant transforms
we list things like the input bucket
with our VCF the output table in
bigquery a temp location and then some
information about our product at the
bottom you'll also see a Google
pipeline's
command we're actually running variant
transforms through Google pipelines just
like we did before
so once that starts we get that
operation we can come to compute engine
and we can see the main node here that
we've started and this is the worker
that's actually going to kick off that
dataflow job so then coming into data
flow we can start to get into the
specifics of that run we can follow it
to see where it's at in the process
understand the resource consumption and
once it's done we'll go into bigquery to
see the output coming into the dataset
in table you'll see the schema listed
here and this is the schema that we use
for variance and you can see the
information as well as the types for
example so you know how to query that
field we can look at some details about
that showing us the size of the table
the rows the location where it's stored
and then this preview field lets us see
a sample set of the data so it shows us
how the data is stored and if you're
more of a visual learner this is a spot
you can come to see what that looks like
before you start writing your queries so
once it's there bigquery is our server
less scalable data warehouse and
bigquery scales to petabytes of storage
it provides a standard sequel dialect
for doing queries so you don't have to
learn a new language to use it one of
the features is that it actually
separates compute and storage from each
other and so in this case particularly
in a research environment is very
important because as a data host you
know exactly what you're gonna be on the
hook for you upload a data set you're
gonna pay the storage cost of that and
you know you're only gonna pay the
storage cost you're not worried about
what analytic someone else is going to
run against that and as a user you know
that you're paying for an analysis that
you're doing and we show you how to
actually how much you can expect to pay
for those as well as a data host we also
offer a lot of different ways to do
access control and you can do some fine
grained access control as well if you're
providing your data set to different
collaborators for example one of the
ways that we do that is through using
authorized views and authorized views
are a way to let you share your query
results without actually sharing the
underlying data
so let's say you have a table with some
data set and you want to give access to
a subset of that whether that's certain
columns that aren't relevant for that
person maybe it's certain rows or do two
different consent or usage agreements
you're only allowed to provide certain
samples to a particular user in that
case you write a query that pulls out
that subgroup and you save your results
as an authorized view the end user that
you now give access to the authorized
view queries that view as though it were
a table so they don't know anything
different they think that's the table
they use the same syntax and everything
as though they were querying the table
but they don't get access to the
underlying data and you decide what they
get to see some other features in
bigquery our query validation so on the
right here you can see this green check
box and that's going to let us know that
it's a valid query we wrote if it's not
valid we get a little red X if you hover
over that it'll start to give you some
feedback as well and let you know what's
missing in the syntax give you some tips
as to how to maybe fix that and then
next to that the green text is well
tells you how much data it's expected to
process when you run this query so the
cost the pricing model for bigquery is
storage and data processing so time is
not something that you're charged on but
you're charged on the amount of data
that gets processed and so we'll show
you here how much data we expect to
process if you were if you were to run
this query and it lets you understand is
this really a query you want to run or
is it something where maybe you need to
optimize your query before you actually
run that we provide a number of
different ways to actually integrate
with bigquery we have the UI here so if
that's something you're more familiar
with you can run your queries from here
you don't have to leave your browser
window open when you run them your
queries will get started as a job you
can come back and find them later if you
run the same query again results are
cached for an amount of time as well so
that if you're running the same thing
you're not necessarily getting charged
every time you do that we also provide a
command line tool for running your
queries and so in that case that's
something you can run on your local
machine through the Google Cloud SDK
or you can do it through the cloud
console which already has that tool
installed there's also an API for it as
well as a number of client libraries the
client libraries we include right now
our Java Go Python Ruby nodejs and
c-sharp the advantages of this mean that
if you've already got an application in
one of those languages you don't have to
write a separate integration for
bigquery you can import the bigquery
library for your language have your
query happen right there and get your
results in the query so when we're using
bigquery as a variant store one of the
things we need to standardize here is
the schema that we're going to use and
this schema here that we have is based
on a standard VCF and the way we
represent this through a few different
data types so we have simple fields such
as integers and strings we have nested
fields which show up in here listed as a
record and then we also can have
repeated fields as well so in this case
we may have multiple alternate bases and
within alternate bases there are
different ones we want to keep track of
so we represent those as a repeated
nested field we also store the
information from the VFC header so
things that are in format and info for
example you can see at the bottom here
under alternate basis those are things
that we've pulled out of the header and
then we'll go ahead and store those
again we can also put those back into a
into the VCF if you need to pull that
back out of bigquery this is suitable
for storing single sample or multiple
samples and variant transforms when
you're importing is also able to
validate a VCF before you import it so
for example if you have a lot of samples
you're importing it once the last thing
you want is to get all the way to the
end and then have it fail because you
have some malformed records in one of
your files so we can actually do a quick
validation step where it'll go through
before and let you know if there's any
issues and you can decide what you want
to do at that point if it finds a
malformed record whether
want to try to guess what to do if you
want to ignore it if you want to abort
the task though that's something that
you can configure there and then again
as I mentioned the the ability to export
that back to VCF as well because we have
this standard schema we can get it back
to that same spot if you're querying
multiple independently repeated fields
in that case you're gonna actually need
to unnecessaries and the sample set here
is just over 10,000 samples which is
about 361 million variants that we're
using and the initial import of that is
a 23 terabyte table now these were
imported using variant transforms and
actually did this in four batches and
that snapshot we saw earlier from
dataflow was one of the batches where I
was actually adding 2500 more samples to
this existing table now when you're
doing those imports again you decide if
you want a new table or if you want to
append it to an existing one and when
you append it to an existing table it's
an atomic operation so nothing is
actually there until the whole jobs
completed so you don't have to worry
about it failing at the end and ending
up with a mismatch of records or if
someone's running a query while you're
updating the records they'll get one
version or the other depending when they
run the query but you're never going to
get a mix of both so we're gonna go
through the next few slides and look at
some tips for optimizing queries and the
things we're gonna optimize for our run
time storage and the amount of data that
we process now as I mentioned the cost
of bigquery are related to the amount of
data you process and the storage so
those are easy things we would think to
optimize because they drastically can
reduce the cost that we pay for this in
addition run time can also be important
depending what you're using the output
of this query
or if you have other processes in your
business or something else in your lab
that depends on this output there might
be times when the run time is actually
more important to you than the cost or
equally as important so we'll look at
how to optimize there as well
so this first query we're going to look
at a fairly simple one and we're just
counting all the variants and we're
gonna order them by chromosome and so I
do this because this is a query that
shows where we're actually gonna have to
go through and we're gonna have to
process all of the rows because we're
going to count all of the variants so
we're gonna go through and count
everything where there's a genotype
greater than zero
and then we're gonna group those by
chromosome and so in here you'll see
that group by reference name and that's
where we'll go ahead and order those and
once they're ordered we'll actually go
through and we'll count them in each
group and report them back so when we
run this on the initially imported table
it processes about 13 terabytes of data
and takes a little over four minutes to
run that is expensive and time consuming
and we can do much better in both of
those and we'll show you a couple of
techniques of how you can deal with that
so the first optimization technique we
have is partitioning and clustering of
tables now in this case at the bottom
you'll see that we cluster this table on
reference name which is the chromosome
and then the start and end position so
essentially we're taking all the
variants and we're actually lining them
up in order and that's how we're going
to physically store the data so we're
actually going to bigquery is now going
to co-locate the data that's in the same
cluster in the same place so if you have
certain queries they'll be optimized by
knowing where to go and which data you
have to access in this case it can
reduce scans of unnecessary data or in
the case of this particular query the
benefit we get is that now the data is
already grouped so when we try to go
ahead and order those and group them
everything is already clustered together
so it's a much quicker process to do now
you'll notice here in this one the table
is still the same size it's still a 23
terabyte table but we'll expect
the speed increase due to the way that
it's stored so in this just like before
this one's going to process 13 terabytes
of data so again it's still a fairly
expensive query for us and we're not
filtering in this query which is why
we're not saving any of the processing
there but you can see the time that it
took here is just under 45 seconds so
it's over five times faster by having
that data together in the same place the
next type of optimization we're going to
do is starting to optimize for the types
of queries that we're running and so in
this case we take the clustered table
that we have and then extract the call
sets for the homozygous reference calls
because we can infer that from the
reference so we don't need to store a
duplicate of that and then for the no
calls we actually pull that out and just
store the no call as a boolean as a true
or false of is it a no call so in that
case we're now not going to have to
unnecessary that we can check the
boolean and save on the amount of data
we're processing and the amount of data
we're storing so this table now is about
three times smaller than the last one
coming in at just over eight terabytes
and when we run that same query on this
clustered and compacted table we don't
have to process the entire call record
to check if there's a genotype greater
than zero we can figure out which
records those are and in this case we
did it by processing less than a
terabyte of data so in this case we
process 18 times less data than the
original meaning the cost of this query
is five percent or so of what that
original one was not to mention the time
we look at this query now we run it in
under ten seconds which is 25 times
faster than that original table that we
imported so let's look at some of the
other advantages of clustering so this
query now we're doing the same thing we
did before we're doing that variant
count but we're only gonna check
chromosome 1 and the way we're doing it
is with a where clause
now the where clause is not actually
going to change how much data we touch
it's still going to have to go through
and check
the where clause is great at restricting
how much data we get back but it doesn't
really help us with how much data we
process generally and so if we look at
that when we run it you'll see it still
processes 13 terabytes of data now we
did this in 30 seconds as opposed to the
4 minutes because we didn't actually
have to do the group and the count but
we still had to go through all of that
data so when we start to use the
clustered table so now where it's
actually ordered and bigquery knows
where to go to find different sets of
that we can see on the right here that
this one says it may process up to 13
terabytes still now the number we give
there is a worst case scenario we don't
know all the time how much data we're
gonna access until we actually do it we
can give you a worst-case guess of what
we may have to touch so in this case it
says that it could run up to 13
terabytes but when we actually run it
you'll go ahead and see the difference
so in this case we actually only process
one terabyte of data because bigquery
knows where chromosome 1 has been
clustered it only has to hit that
particular section and it knows it can
ignore all the rest of the data in the
table because everything that's
co-located together now it runs in about
the same amount of time around 30
seconds which lets us know that the
majority of the time here is probably
the counting and not the actual finding
of it so the times the same but
processing it is 13 tests 13 times less
data again leading to a direct relation
to our cost reduction now if we keep
optimizing here and we use that
clustered and compacted table the one
where we had pulled out the reference
and the no calls
remember that originally this processed
13 terabytes it took about 30 seconds in
this version we're now only processing
60 gigabytes of data so 200 times less
data that's barely a blip on the price
sheet at this point and we're doing it
five times faster still in coming in at
just under six seconds to do that same
that same count
so next if we look at a little more
complicated query if we're checking the
transition to transversion snips this is
a query that will require accessing
almost all of the data so we expect that
we're gonna actually have to touch most
of our entire table on the originally
imported data this processed 20
terabytes out of our original 23
terabyte table and came in at just over
8 minutes so we'll look at a couple
different things here of using those
same optimized tables we had before to
see what the impact is on this
particular query so again this
calculation still requires accessing the
same amount of data so on a clustered
table it didn't save us anything on our
actual cost of computation we still had
to touch about 20 terabytes of data but
we did cut the time in half and now ran
it in about three and a half minutes
instead of the original eight so when we
start to look at what's important to
your business for a particular task this
is an option where even something like
clustering can still help with some
areas of performance and you can find
what the best optimization is for the
types of queries you're using when we
run this on that clustered and compact
table we've now cut the time to be less
than a minute and in this case it
processes about seven terabytes now
remember this was an eight terabyte
table to begin with so we're still
touching almost the entire table but
we're it's it's still a significantly
lower amount of data that we're having
to touch and again about three times
faster coming in at just under a minute
so as we go through this we're currently
looking at reviewing some of the schemas
we have as well as some of these
optimization techniques to go ahead and
see what we can do to provide optimized
schemas or provide best practices for
certain types of queries so again this
another area would love to solicit
feedback if you've got certain queries
that you're running or things that
aren't working well or things you're
looking to optimize we've got a mailing
list that we'll discuss at the end
that's got a number of users of the
product as well as a bunch of members of
our team and we can help try to figure
out what's the best solution for you and
see if there's something we can bring
back to the community
there as well so one of the other
advantages with bigquery is using the
client libraries such as the Python
client library to integrate with Jupiter
notebooks so in this you can connect
your Jupiter notebook directly to
bigquery which will use bigquery to do
the compute and all the heavy lifting of
any of the filtering and ordering to
give you your data back and you're not
depending on your hosted runtime to
actually do the hard computations so the
way this works you paste your query as
an argument when you've imported the
bigquery library you run that you get
the results back in your notebook and if
you've got something in there already
where you're using a data frame for
example you can get that data back from
bigquery put that into the data frame
and not have to change the existing
notebook you have and keep using your
same analysis just changing the data
source that you're using on the backend
some different options we have for
running notebooks here include
collaboratory which is product by the
research team at Google that they
provide for use and this is hosted on a
Google back-end although there are
limitations to the the runtime and what
you can choose since it's a hosted
environment there's cloud data lab which
is a product that you run in your own
Google cloud platform project and allows
you to host a notebook there that you
want to connect to and then we've got a
product that we announced this week as
well that went to beta called AI
platform notebooks and this is
essentially Jupiter notebooks as a
service and this supports a variety of
different frameworks and packages
including tensor flow and pi torch as
well as a lot of packages pre-installed
that people are used to like numpy and
whatnot now a our platform notebooks
also has a built in integration with
github so we can use that for syncing or
backing up our notebooks and also using
that to share among other people so if
you need to share your notebooks with
collaborators either in your lab in your
company with others you can do that
through github in a way that you're
already used to and we can also attach
different types of CPUs or attach GPUs
to those
form notebooks as well so if you've got
tasks where you're using tensorflow for
example you can choose which GPUs you
want that are appropriate for that and
then of course you can always host your
own jupiter notebook as well so if you
already have your own environment set up
and you've already got hosted notebooks
bring in the bigquery client library and
you can now utilize the benefits of
bigquery with the notebooks that you've
already got so let's take a look at a
couple other tools we have here as well
for doing analysis and we're gonna look
at data proc being one of those and then
we'll get into a couple of the partner
tools as well that we have so first off
one of the partner tools that I want to
mention recent addition here is that we
now have support for para bricks through
the marketplace in Google cloud platform
so para bricks has written a GPU
optimized version of gatk best practices
and deep variant and in this case
they're able to take what was about a 30
hour run and turn that into 45 minutes
so this is now available for you to
launch in cloud marketplace it runs in
your environment and allows you to bring
services like this to run in your own in
your own project the other part to note
is if you're a developer who's building
tools like this this is a way that you
can actually provide that and make that
available as well and simplify running
that on Google clouds infrastructure so
that your end customers don't have to
figure any of that out so let's take a
look at going through here we'll start
by pulling it up in marketplace and go
ahead and launch that on compute and we
can choose the types of GPUs we want
like a V 100 we choose how many we want
to attach and go ahead and start that
once it's up and running we're going to
SSH into our instance and in this case
we're going to copy our license over and
set a couple of inputs here and a
reference as well and those are all
coming from GCS buckets we're then going
to go ahead and run that through this
connection and as this is running again
it's going to process it
save our output to its storage bucket
that we defined and again this shows it
in a way that you can now bring this
directly into your project or for the
developers of this tool this is a way
that they can deploy and monetize that
as well so lastly I want to talk about
data proc at a high level here so data
proc is our managed service for Apache
spark and Hadoop environments and this
can be used for a variety of tools one
of them right now that we're using is
for hail so using this to run a genomic
analysis framework doing things like gee
wasps and we're able to run that through
data proc which will handle all of the
nodes for you and again as we look at
the world of notebooks we can also then
connect the notebook to that as well so
if we want to just submit our job
directly to that cluster or if we want
to connect a notebook to that cluster we
can then run the job through the
notebook as well so I hope that gives
good introduction to some of the tools
we have in this space and helps cover
some of the questions you might have
some of the resources that we discussed
here that are available with links as
well and we've got links here to some of
the documentation and the tutorials that
we used and then as I mentioned as well
we have a mailing list at the top and
that Google genomics discuss mailing
lists you can join that from our
genomics documentation page and this
list consists of a number of users of
these products from around the world as
well as members of our solutions team
and our product and engineering teams so
if you have issues if you have questions
if something's not working if you're
trying something new that you can't
figure out it's a great place to go and
see if there's someone who may have
already done that if there's other
contributors in the field who can help
out or if you've got questions for the
engineering team as to how we can help
better improve these products
[Music]